[Musique]
le panel Hélène buzetti Michel surgel à
castongue bonsoir
bonsoir
Marie-Eve pro qui finalement député
kakis de côte du Sud retire sa
candidature Sébastien nous disait en
pleine campagne parce que même si le
déclenchement n'est pas n'est pas fait
on est quand même en pleine campagne
c'est plutôt malaisant en tout cas
plutôt rare tour de table là-dessus
est-ce que Hélène
elle dit qu'elle a pris sa décision
seule on peut passer que le parti en
tout cas voulait éviter des d'être
agacés avec ce sujet là on peut le
penser en même temps c'est quand même
étrange parce que le premier ministre
l'avait défendu encore il y a quelques
semaines à peine mais effectivement ça
ressemblait peut-être de plus en plus à
un boulet vous savez quand vous avez une
ou deux personnes qui se plaignent de
climat toxique on peut peut-être mettre
ça sur le compte d'un conflit de
personnalité lorsque vous êtes rendu
avec beaucoup plus de nom voir même une
vingtaine de personnes qui ont quitté le
bureau ça devient un petit peu plus
difficile
il y a peut-être une question plus large
aussi à poser et puis c'est un peu
délicat ce que je vais dire mais ça fait
plusieurs femmes quand même en position
d'autorité qui se font accuser
d'instaurer un climat toxique au travail
je parle je pense à Nathalie bondyl ou
musée des Beaux-Arts on a eu Julie Payet
il y avait l'ex-minis Marie pour mon
petit plusieurs anciennes journalistes
la dernière en liste Lisa la flamme il y
a quand même beaucoup de noms et c'est à
se demander s'il y a peut-être pas un
apprentissage du pouvoir qui est
peut-être un peu ardue qui se fait du
côté des femmes en tout cas il y a un
enjeu me semble-t-il qu'il faudrait
aborder et je pense qu'on est tous un
peu timide à le faire parce que c'est
délicat ou bien que le que la barre
n'est pas à la même hauteur pour les
femmes et les hommes que le qu'on est
moins tolérant pour des femmes qui en
position pouvoir comme bref Michel c'est
og qu'est-ce que est-ce que ça vous
inspire
il s'est dit plusieurs choses et
beaucoup de choses contradictoires dans
ce point de presse là entre autres quand
on fait une règlement hors course qu'on
admet quelque chose quand même mais
quand tout ça a été dit une chose qui
est vrai qui est totalement la raison
pour laquelle elle ne sera pas là elle
ne veut pas et on ne veut pas à la carte
qu'elle soit une diversion dans une
campagne électorale la pire affaire qui
peut arriver c'est que le jour où le
Premier ministre son annonce sur
l'agriculture ou sur les transports en
commun il y a des questions sur ce qui
arrive avec sa député qui a des qui a
des problèmes alors à la fin que ce soit
sa décision ou pas sa décision c'est pas
très important il est clair que la
campagne ne voulait pas avoir la
possibilité
pas juste de développer parce que c'est
pas ça que c'est arrivé mais de perdre
une journée là-dessus avec
je pense que c'est ça la décision et je
pense que François Legault a accepté
avec en train je pense que les deux sont
tout à fait possible c'est à dire
qu'elle commençait à avoir des
difficultés avec les maires de sa région
aussi elle voyait bien qu'aucus de la
CAQ elle n'allait pas avoir une carrière
politique ascendante c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire on n'allait pas
réintégrer le Conseil des ministres et
effectivement peut-être que c'est dit
tant que avoir les projecteurs sur moi
pour les mauvaises raisons c'est bien
parti et je pense que François Legault a
trouvé que c'était une bonne idée mais
on n'a pas de candidates ou de candidats
pour la remplacer c'est ce qui prouve
qu'on l'a pas poussé vers la sortie on a
personne à annoncer on va retenter de
régler ça cette semaine à la CAQ on a
des candidats qui sont envisagés mais on
avait personne en réserve la République
au coq c'est ce qui me fait dire que je
pense que c'est sa décision à elle sinon
on aurait pu annoncer en 24 heures qui
la remplace ce sera pas le cas ça va
prendre un peu de temps donc au-delà de
ce qui est
ou non avéré dans son cabinet je ne
connais pas les relations personnelles
de Madame proue avec son personnel je ne
sais pas ce qui est vrai ou pas vrai
mais c'est clair que elle était mieux de
quitter maintenant que dans la première
semaine de la campagne où là on brûle
pour le chef une journée deux journées à
se défendre ou plutôt qu'à être sur le
message alors elle fait une fleur à son
chef en quittant une semaine avant le
déclenchement et vous dites presque que
ça soit un juste ou pas c'est la dure
réalité de la politique
la perception qui compte très bien bon
alors je dis c'est parti hier on va voir
les images le Parti conservateur du
Québec alors c'est carrément sa campagne
il y avait beaucoup de monde monsieur
Duhem était là il dit on va c'est bon
pour la démocratie on sera suivi nous
etc
promesse aujourd'hui et des piquets sur
365 dollars pour une passe pour le
transport en commun qui serait multi
région le Québec solidaire qui propose
de l'aide pour les garderies alors on
est vraiment lancé est-ce qu'on doit
s'étonner de ça d'abord Michel vous
première impressions sur ce début de
campagne
dans une système d'élection adaptique il
faut pas s'en m'étonner ce qui est
étonnant un peu c'est que monsieur
Legault a dit à la fin de la session
parlementaire on propose nous pendant la
période pré électorale on fera pas ça et
finalement ils sont tous en train de le
faire mais la CAC en premier alors ça
c'est un peu étonnant mais à partir du
moment où on sait la date écoutez aux
élections aux États-Unis les élections
du 1 an alors
se retiennent pas pour par rapport à
tendre le mois de septembre pour parler
là alors à la fin c'est un peu
inévitable dans le système des élections
d'Afrique il faudra peut-être
réglementer c'est les dépenses c'est une
autre affaire la publicité télévisée des
choses comme ça mais des promesses ça se
ça exigeait
en fait j'abond dans le sens de Michel
je trouve que ça a toujours été le côté
pervers de ces élections à date fixe
autre le fait en plus qu'on perd une
année de nos mandats qui sont supposés
durer selon la Constitution 5 ans et
donc pas 4 on l'oublie un peu mais oui
ça fait en sorte qu'il y a plus vraiment
de coup de départ tout le monde peut
commencer avant on devrait me
semble-t-il
s'inspirer de ce qui fait de ce qui se
fait à Ottawa quoique encore là il y a
des entorses mais de réglementer les
dépenses pré-électorales il y a un
certain contrôle mais bon même ça ça ne
fonctionne que lorsqu'on respecte le
calendrier des élections à date fixe la
dernière élection l'année dernière
monsieur Trudeau était allé de manière
prématurée et donc ça ne s'était pas
appliqué il y a un facteur de la date
fixe bien sûr puis on connaît le jour du
scrutin donc on peut commencer avant
mais Alex il y a aussi le fait qu'elle
est particulièrement courte elle sera
particulièrement courte la campagne
c'est comme on voulait pas perdre de
temps puis être
en fait le lien va pas être la Tortue
dans ce cas-ci
il va faire la campagne la plus courte
possible éviter les dérapages puis
essayer de se rendre jusqu'au bout
contrairement à mes collègues je suis un
peu étonné quand même du sang gêne de
ces annonces pré électorales la
publicité ça c'est assez prévisible les
parties qui ont plus d'argent font de la
publicité pendant l'été pendant les
campagnes électorales mais là que tous
les partis envoient des communiqués de
presse annonce électorales en bonne et
due fort avec les mises en scène
Dominique Anglade qui s'en va dans un
endroit pour acheter le matériel
scolaire de ses enfants puis des mises
en scène dans des parcs la campagne elle
n'est même pas commencé encore je
pensais qu'on se garderait une petite
gêne un peu plus longtemps ça fait déjà
deux semaines presque des annonces de
campagne électorales un moment donné
c'est un peu ridicule je comprends
pourquoi la carte le fait dans le sens
où c'est plus porteur de faire une
annonce en tant que gouvernement Premier
ministre en fonction on je vais vous
présenter comme le ministre de
l'Environnement ou le ministre de la
Santé qui fait une annonce ça a plus de
porter que le candidat kakis tout le
chef cachiste mais de là annoncé comme
ça chaque jour des annonces électorales
alors qu'on n'est pas encore en campagne
je trouve que ça perverti quand même un
petit peu le système je veux croire
qu'on sait la date là il me semble qu'on
aurait pu se garder un petit jeune ou
alors faisons une campagne plus longue
et à ce moment-là plutôt que de faire
semblant qu'elle doit être courte parce
que à un moment donné c'est un peu
ridicule effectivement on a on a on a
fait un tableau avec les slogans on
avait à peu près tous les slogans la
semaine dernière sauf celui du Parti
québécois alors on va les prendre puis
vous allez me dire si c'est un bon coup
un mauvais coup je sens que vous allez
me dire aussi que dans le fond les
slogans on en parle la première journée
on en parle plus mais quand même c'est
révélateur prenons la CACT tour de table
sur la carte continuons bon ça me semble
une évidence Hélène
je trouve que ça fonctionne très bien
moi je sais pas si ciné que par rapport
aux slogan c'est pas ça qui transforme
une campagne électorale c'est pour ça
qui fait que vous votez pour un
participe mais je trouve que ça
encapsule le message la mission que ça
donne un parti politique dans un
contexte de campagne donné et dans ce
cas-ci je trouve que ça encapsule
parfaitement lac qu'est-ce que la carte
nous dit essentiellement
on est super bon dans les sondages mais
on continue Michel
quand j'ai vu ça j'ai pensé je me suis
souvenu que Tom malker quand c'était
chef d'une [ __ ] il finissait toucher le
discours on continue je me suis dit ce
qu'ils vont lui donner des royauté je ne
sais pas mais effectivement et Hélène a
raison à un moment donné la seule chose
que la carte demande en réalité c'est de
continuer d'avoir un autre mandat et
quand on est très en avance comme ça
c'est une façon de faire qui se qui est
tout à fait normal d'un autre côté ça se
met mal dans la campagne si ça dérape
continuons c'est moins une fois
j'imagine j'imagine qu'il se disent on
verra propre là on va accélérer
pas aussi efficace que le maintenant de
2018 mais pas mal plus efficace que on
se donne le goût de 2014
on passe à l'autre le prochain slogan on
va voir on va revoir le tableau donc
alors ça c'est voter vrai enjeux vrai
solution mais c'est le vote est vrai des
libères autour de table plus rapide je
commence à le voir avec
quand on a des longs slogans c'est qu'on
a généralement de la difficulté en
capsuler le message d'en parler Hélène
on essaie de dire beaucoup de choses
pour faire la bien des gens voter vrai
enjeux vraies solutions ça me rappelle
un peu 2014 les vrais affaires de
Philippe Couillard on a assez
probablement de jouer dans ces talents
mais je le trouve peut-être un petit peu
long et moins efficace que celui de 2014
et un moment donné c'est accusé tout le
monde accepté soi-même de mentir je suis
pas sûr que c'est très que c'est très
utile comme cela ok Hélène avez-vous de
malade non et je le comprends pas en
fait je ne sais pas à quoi ça fait
référence alors je le trouve pas
efficace bon changer d'air là il y a un
jeu de mots mais quand on le voit écrit
vous allez le voir écrit changer d'air
c'est Québec solidaire qu'on change
totalement notre façon de gouverner la
société
Hélène commence avec vous changer d'air
pour Québec solide moi je trouve ça
fonctionne bien parce que ça représente
ce que eux proposent un changement de
paradigme politique on n'est pas comme
c'est vieux de la CAQ nous on a une
nouvelle façon de penser on est moderne
on est progressiste on est jeune je
trouve que ça représente bien ce qu'ils
offrent aux électeurs très bien Michel
changer d'air
qui était intéressant ce qui marche pas
par exemple c'est la photo qui va avec
le gros mot Neo
réninien des deux chefs par exemple mais
le changer d'air c'est peut-être la
meilleure
ok allez
plus japonais que je te l'ai installée
le soleil levant quelque chose je
comprends la référence
le double sens avec l'environnement
changer d'air changer d'époque aussi
fonctionne plutôt bien mais je suis
d'accord que le visuel peut-être pas le
plus réussi ok le Parti québécois le
Québec qui s'assume pour vrai
et d'un tour de table rapide et là eux
aussi vrai c'est un peu verbeux comme
disait on disait à propos de l'autre
slogan libéral
par condensé incarne un peu ce qu'ils
veulent dire en fait il dit la casse ils
sont nationalistes mais ils ne vont pas
jusqu'au bout de leur logique nous au
moins on est cohérent mais c'est très
long pour un slogan et ça témoigne
encore là d'un parti qui a de la misère
à se présenter à se concevoir lui-même
ouais c'est comme si on voulait parler
une base électorale qui est déjà
conquise ceux qui ne sont pas à la CAQ
actuellement parce qu'il n'en fait pas
assez d'un point de vue nationaliste
souverainiste ben il y en a 9 à 10 % et
ils sont au PQ alors est-ce que les
autres qui sont satisfaits de la carte
les autres électeurs qui trouvent que la
coque en fait juste assez est-ce que ça
peut les ramener au Parti québécois j'ai
des doutes là Michel un mot
le pari de la campagne c'est de dire il
y a plus d'indépendantistes que Jack
prêt à voter pour le Parti québécois
donc allons les chercher c'est un groupe
et Monsieur duem Parti conservateur du
Québec libre chez nous qui renvoie à
d'autres slogans d'une autre époque tour
de table Hélène je le trouve très
efficace je trouve que ça correspond à
la campagne monsieur semaine on était
plusieurs à pouvoir faire de la
politique mais la politique c'est
tellement Méline nos vies au cours des
deux dernières années que là on se met
de politique ça correspond à leur
électorat c'est d'une durée de éphémère
mais pour l'instant ça marche Michel
c'est
ça rappelle le fait que ce sont des
libertés de ce parti-là je suis pas sûr
que c'était des logements
et puis conclusion Alec
je pense que ça veut dire d'être libre
chez nous personne le sait mais ça parle
peut-être à tout le monde alors il doit
y avoir
merci à vous trois si elle a lancé la
saison à très bientôt au revoir bonne
soirée pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI